- I say he will be better.
- I think he will be better than me.
I have like three plates
in my room right now.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- We've been roommates for a year
and a couple of months.
- It was roommate at first sight.
(laughs)
- We've been roommates
since November 2015.
- And that's six or seven months.
- We went to grad school together.
- We're roommates and
we're also best friends.
(giggles)
- We've been friends since
we were nine years old.
- And we've been
roommates for about a year
and a half.
We did have like a period where
we had to like, learn each other.
- Lots of tears guys.
(laughs)
- We've been roommates
just short of two years.
We didn't know each other at all.
The first year was a little rough.
- We weren't on the same page.
I did use your hair
product today, as well.
- Yeah.
- Without asking.
(upbeat music)
- How long is an acceptable amount of time
to leave washing up?
I usually do like a couple of days.
- I think it should be
within a 24 hours period.
- What time should you try
to be quiet around the house?
- Oh, we're both, like, super quiet.
We're like little mice people.
- Yeah like our neighbors
probably don't realize
that our apartment is occupied.
- All the time, all noise is bad.
- Yup that's you.
You could be as noisy as you want.
- That's your feelings?
- Yup.
- You've run out of clean underwear,
what do you do?
- This is triggering question.
- I stopped taking your underwear.
It has been, like,
years since I took her underwear.
Or a year.
- I don't even wear underwear.
- Probably like six months.
- I'm going commando.
- I'm probably going to wear the same ones
until I wash new ones.
- I would let you borrow my underwear,
rather than you walk
around in dirty underwear.
- What foods are communal?
- I did give pizza,
Kari pizza, the other night.
- Oh and I meant to text you
I have pizza that you could have too
- Oh my god.
- Because we got it Saturday.
- We're pretty good at texting each other
and asking if we could eat something.
- Our third roommate--
- Our third roommate doesn't do that.
- isn't the best at that.
- You and your housemates
discover a dead mouse under your sofa,
what do you do?
(screams)
- This is really real for us right now.
- This is real right now.
- Run away screaming.
- I'll remove the dead mouse.
- You and your housemates need to sort out
how to pay bills,
what do you do?
(laughs)
- I ignore the situation.
I usually just find out what I owe.
- I pay all the bills.
- What bother you the most?
- Probably just dirt mess.
- I didn't know that I was that messy.
- No, I was.
No, not--
(laughs)
- Your housemate brings
the person they're dating
over for the first time,
what do you do?
Oh, we have such a good story about his.
- We have a few good stories.
- Hang around as much as possible,
and maybe follow them around a bit
to embarrass them.
I think I've done that.
- Yeah, you've done that.
- Your housemates partner
is spending more nights at the house
than not.
What do you do?
- What if she just sucked.
- You're gonna sleep here,
you're gonna to pay the rent.
- Someone has eaten the last cookie
in the packet you bought,
what do you do?
- You would shrug and
say it's just a cookie,
but you'd passive aggressively be angry.
- No, I screamed at him.
(upbeat music)
- We did it,
we're still friends.
She's a great roommate.
- We're both gonna be an
81 in a couple of months.
- Yes.
(laughing)
- I think the test is rigged.
That's what I expected.
- This just told us the truth.
- That once again,
healthy communication is key.
- I got 62 points?!
I'm honestly shocked.
Oh yeah,
does your roommate, like, massage you
and cuddle you when
you're having a bad day?
Because mine does.
(upbeat music)
- It was fun.
- [Ajiri] Yeah, super fun.
- But definitely save up,
so you can buy your own place.
- [Tristan] Yeah, that's the best one.